rallumer les projecteurs éteints faire
remonter sur scène des artistes de la
région
voilà l'objectif de ce speed dating
culturelles organisées à châteauroux
pour la première fois speed dating c'est
comme sur le modèle amoureux c'est une
rencontre entre des programmateurs et
des équipes artistiques toutes les 15
minutes
un gong retentit et le groupe change de
table
l'enjeu pour ces compagnies locales
convaincre les professionnels de
programmer leur spectacle elles ont
quinze minutes pas une de plus elle
c'est un opéra numérique adolescents
connectés c'est hyper rapide
c'est le principe du speed dating non
mais c'est cool c'est bien parce que du
coup ça permet d'être efficace il faut
être condensé dans son projet sa parole
puis ça permet quand même de rencontrer
les professionnels voilà dans une époque
un peu bizarre de kobe grâce à ces
rencontres
ce programmateur a fini par trouver la
perle rare je pense avoir trouvé un joli
spectacle jeune public autour de la
musique qui pourrait être très joli chez
nous je pense que ça nous permet
effectivement de poser des poser des
mots et poser des aussi des visages un
parfois sur des élections des projets
dont on a connaissance parfois vaguement
ça me permettra d'aller plus haut à quoi
pour emmanuel et christine sur les
planches depuis 1992 pas de speed dating
mais une présentation de leur spectacle
devant un public uniquement composé de
professionnels avec à la clé peut-être
de nouvelles dates
ça fait monter peut-être encore plus un
petit peu la pression nous on a créé ce
spectacle en janvier à issoudun
et puis bah ça ça a été un peu
interrompu comme pour beaucoup d'autres
compagnies bien sûr donc oui on compte
sur cet événement de région scène pour
relancer le relancer la machine
dans la salle le public est attentif et
concentré
ce nouveau match le secteur culturel va
peut-être enfin se remettre en mouvement